problem one for zero is less than or
equal to t is less than or equal to six
a particle is moving along the x-axis
the particle's position x of t is not
explicitly given the velocity of the
particle is given by v of t is equal to
all of this business right over here the
acceleration of the particle is given by
a of t is equal to all of this business
over here they actually didn't have to
give us that because the acceleration is
just the derivative of the velocity and
they also give us they don't tell us the
position function but they tell us where
we start off x of 0 is equal to 2. fair
enough now let's do part a
is the speed of the particle increasing
or decreasing at time t equals 5.5 give
a reason for your answer it looks like
they did something a little sneaky here
because they gave us a velocity function
and then they ask about a speed and you
might say wait aren't those the same
thing and i would say you know they
aren't quite the same thing velocity is
a magnitude and a direction it is a
vector quantity speed is just a
magnitude it is a scalar quantity and to
see the difference you could have a
velocity and this isn't maybe particular
to this problem because they don't give
us the units but you could have a
velocity of negative 5 meters per second
and maybe if we're talking about on the
x-axis this would mean we're moving
leftward at five meters per second on
the x-axis so the magnitude is five
meters per second this is the magnitude
magnitude and the direction is specified
by the negative number and that is the
direction
your velocity could be negative 5 meters
per second but your speed your speed
would just be would just be 5 meters per
second so your speed is 5 meters per
second whether you're going to the left
or to the right your velocity you
actually care whether you're going to
the left or the right so let's just keep
that in mind while we try to solve this
problem
so the best way to figure out whether
our rate of change is increasing or
decreasing is to look at the
acceleration
because acceleration is really just the
rate of change of velocity and then we
can think a little bit about this this
this this velocity versus speed question
so what is the acceleration at time 5.5
get the calculator out we can use
calculators for this part of the ap exam
and i i assume they intend us to because
this isn't something that's easy to
calculate by hand so the acceleration at
time 5.5 we just have to say t is 5.5
and evaluate this function
so one half i'll just write 0.5 times
e
to the t over 4. well t is 5.5 5.5
divided by 4
and then times cosine
times cosine of
times cosine of
5.5 divided by 4. 5.5
divided by 4
gives us
gives us
0.38 did i do that right we have 0.5
times e to the 5.5 divided by 4 times
cosine oh sorry i made a mistake
that looked a little strange it's not
cosine of 5.5 divided by 4. it's cosine
of e to the cosine of e to the
5.5 divided by 4. so let's look at that
so that's one parenthesis i closed and
now that is the second parentheses that
i've closed and i get negative 1.3 well
i'll just say roughly negative 1.36
so this is equal to or approximately
equal to negative 1.36 if i round it and
we don't care about so much as the
actual value
what we really care about is its sine so
the acceleration the acceleration at
time 5.5 is negative which tells us that
the velocity
the velocity is
the velocity is decreasing
now you might be tempted to say we're
done but remember they're not asking us
is the velocity of the particle
increasing or decreasing they're asking
us is the speed is the speed of the
particle increasing or decreasing and if
you're saying hey how did i know that
just remember acceleration is just the
rate of change of velocity if if
acceleration is negative that means the
rate of change of velocity is negative
it is going down but anyway how do we
address this speed issue how do we think
about it
well there's two scenarios if our
velocity is positive at time 5.5 so if
we have a positive velocity so let's say
our velocity is 5 meters per second
although they don't give us units here
so i won't use units so let's say our
velocity is 5 and then it's negative so
at some point our velocity is going to
be something smaller then that means
that the speed would also be decreasing
so if we have a positive velocity then
the fact that acceleration is negative
means that both velocity and speed would
be decreasing on the other hand if we
had a negative velocity
if we have a negative velocity at time t
equals 5.5
then the fact that it's decreasing means
that we're getting even more negative
and if we're getting even more negative
then that means the speed is increasing
the magnitude is increasing in the
leftward direction so what we really
need to do is beyond just evaluating the
acceleration at time 5.5 we also have to
evaluate the velocity to see if it's
going in the left or in the left or the
rightward direction
so let's evaluate the velocity the
velocity at 5.5 and we'll just get our
calculator out again
velocity at 5.5 we need this is our
velocity function is going to be equal
to 2 times the sine
of
let me write it this way just because i
want to make sure i get my parentheses
right 2
times
the sign actually
2 times let me write this way 2
2 sine
of
e
of e to the 5.5 that's our time divided
by 4.
so i did that part right over here and
i'm going to close the 2 as well
and then plus 1. so this is our velocity
so our velocity at time 5.5 is negative
so negative 0.45 negative 0.45 roughly
so this is negative velocity is negative
velocity is negative
so we have this scenario where the
velocity is negative which means we're
going in the left direction and the fact
that the velocity is also decreasing
means that over time at at least at this
point in time as we go forward in time
it'll become even more negative and
it'll become even more negative if we
wait a little bit longer so that means
that the magnitude of the velocity is
increasing it's just going in the
leftward direction so if the magnitude
of the velocity is increasing although
it's going in the leftward direction
that means that the speed is increasing
so the velocity so this is one of those
interesting scenarios the velocity is in
decreasing but the speed the speed which
is what they're asking us in
in the question speed is increasing
speed is increasing and if you wanted to
do it really quick with all of this
explanation i gave you say hey look
what's acceleration is it positive or
negative you would evaluate it say hey
it's negative so you know velocity is
decreasing and then you would say hey
what is velocity is it positive or
negative you evaluate it you say it's
negative so you have a negative value
that is decreasing so it's becoming more
negative so that means this magnitude is
increasing or speed is increasing